the Donald Trump Republican chat tax
plan continues to move forward the House
has now voted to pass it we are now
waiting to see what's going to happen
with the Senate version and I thought
that today we would go through a couple
of specific groups that are really going
to get hit with tax increases as a
result of this plan depending on which
version passes right and a big selling
point of the Trump tax plan all along
has been it will be a tax cut for mostly
everyone that's the talking point now
we've already analyzed it enough to know
that on paper it's going to be a
reduction in the rate for a lot of
people the tax bracket that lots of
people will be in but depending on the
specifics of everybody's situation it
might actually be a tax increase for
many lower and middle-income families
and it would depend on a number of
factors family size what else standard
deductions personal exemptions other
deductions that are in there that may
stay change or go
what is definitely true is that it will
be the most advantageous to the rich the
ultra rich and the super ultra rich
right to people who are also earning
money through pass through business
entities through corporate to
corporations it will be really good but
now we have some specific examples of
people who are going to pay more and one
is families earning under seventy five
thousand dollars per year there's a
reality here which isn't being talked
about a lot which is that there are
parts of this proposal that expire which
lower taxes and parts that don't expire
that raise taxes or at least counteract
some of those tax reductions so for
example under the Senate version of this
plan which has not yet been voted on
families earning under seventy five
thousand dollars a year are going to on
average see a tax increase
after provisions expire in 2027
and in fact two-thirds of households of
all households in the United States fall
into the brackets that would end up
having a tax increase after the
temporary tax lowering provisions expire
so the big picture becomes even more the
rich will pay way less now and
pay way less in the future whereas the
middle-class is going to end up paying
more as a result of at least the current
Senate version of the bill why would we
want the middle class to pay more in
taxes the middle class are actually the
ones that would spend their extra money
they got any at their local business and
in ways that would actually be good for
the economy the rich are way more likely
to park that extra cash in places that
are not nearly as good for the economy
savings accounts offshore accounts in
other countries altogether another group
that's going to be really hurt by the
Trump tax plan is graduate students who
are pursuing advanced degrees including
PhDs you might know this you might not
grad students mostly make very little
money in 2012 more than half of graduate
students made under 20 grand a year
okay in the House version of the plan
which again this version already passed
last week the House version of the plan
will make it so that tuition fee waivers
for students become taxable income let
me explain that in another way to be
super clear what this means
most PhD students in many fields they go
to school almost for free or in fact
they get a small stipend for going to
school and studying and also being a
teacher's assistant for undergraduate
class they have tuition waived right if
they have had thirty thousand dollars in
tuition waived under the tax plan that
the house has agreed to they would have
to report that thirty thousand dollars
as if it were income which would push
them into a higher tax bracket and they
will end up paying a bunch of taxes on
money that they didn't actually earn it
was just a discount from tuition this
will especially hurt the most advanced
students right undergraduate masters PhD
PhD students are the most likely to be
in these situations and this has
particularly sinister effects when you
consider that the Republican Party is
increasingly hostile to science and if
you don't want science to develop
hurting PhD students through the tax
code is not a bad idea and I have one
example
imagine a PhD student here down the road
at MIT this is a high example right then
we'll talk about average this is an
example that's given by a write-up on
nature calm a typical stipend for a PhD
student at MIT through the NIH is about
twenty four thousand dollars if your
income is twenty four thousand dollars
you pay pretty small amounts on taxes
you just paying taxes on what you
actually earn under the House version of
the bill that was passed MIT tuition
would be added to the twenty four
thousand that the student actually makes
MIT tuition happens to be forty nine
thousand dollars which means that you
earn twenty four thousand dollars but
your taxable income
once that waive tuition is added in is
seventy three thousand dollars and you
end up owing way more money in taxes now
that's a high example sometimes tuition
would be fifteen thousand twenty-five
thousand thirty five thousand but you
get the idea this is a disincentive to
pursue advanced degrees which is exactly
what an administration hostile to
science would do we've seen the Trump
administration be hostile to climate
science being done by NASA hostile to
climate research being done by the EPA
hostile to scientists who say that
certain chemicals are carcinogenic and
they should be banned they don't like
that so this is a great way to pay for
part of the tax cuts for the rich and to
attack science it's a trifecta in in a
sense for the Trump administration and
I'll remind you the david pakman show is
an s-corporation right this plan would
be good for me but I am against it
because it's horrible and it's the
definition of class warfare it is
handouts for the rich and for
corporations while the middle class and
people studying foot the bill but only
part of the bill because it will still
increase our deficit by 1.7 trillion
dollars so what needs to happen number
one call your senators if you oppose
this tax plan the Senate is next to vote
on this the house is already voted
number two Democratic candidates for
2018 need to be campaigning on your
elected official said they would lower
your taxes but they've raised your taxes
those are two things that need to start
happening right away and we've got to
prevent this
from passing in the Senate which is the
next step I am not yet sure when the
Senate is going to vote but they want to
get this done before the end of the year
hopefully it doesn't happen the video
you just finished watching was made
possible by you through the membership
program you can sign up for membership
at david pakman.com slash membership we
are viewer supported independent media
you can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership